est-ce qu'on fait lorsqu'on gère un
immense site d'enfouissement qui reçoit
des centaines de chargement d'ordures
par jour et qui produit quotidiennement
plus de cent mille litres d'eaux usées
et toxiques
on plante des saules beaucoup de soul
160000 et on les arrose avec des eaux
usées qu'on appelle du lixiviat le luxe
il ya cédé aux pluies les précipations
qui perd colle à travers les déchets ils
nous ont un système de captage pour
récolter toutes ces eaux là puis
actuellement on les traite avec un
traitement biologique cinq ans ici à
nous intéressons table de sainte-sophie
wealth management cherchait depuis
longtemps une solution plus écologique
pour gérer ces eaux usées le problème le
lixiviats est extrêmement riche en azote
et en phosphore des fertilisants mais à
des niveaux toxiques pour la majorité
des plantes
sauf pour une variété de sol sélectionné
par des chercheurs du jardin botanique
non seulement ces plantes aux lettres
est bien le lixiviats mais elles
agissent comme un filtre en retenant les
produits toxiques dans leurs tiges et
leurs feuilles
en fait c'est soyons 7,7 quelle idée
enfin ce défaut plutôt que ceux qui
consomment beaucoup d'eau quand on veut
traiter des lixiviats c'est intéressant
on va les arrosées avec de l'eau de
lixiviats en question qu'ils vont
absorber beaucoup qui vont transpirer
dans l'atmosphère et c'est une façon de
limiter le rejet à l'environnement ou à
la rigueur c'est une équipe de
polytechnique montréal qui a conçu la
recette de lixiviats parfaite pour
maximiser la croissance des choses ce
que l'on a vu le des risques de donner
un dans des petits pots de mètres cubes
dont km² 1 mètre de hauteur
c'est que ça permet de doubler la
croissance des soins parce que des
nutriments azote et phosphore et
potassium en particulier et donc c'est
bénéfique
on se débarrasse des eaux usées on
accélère la croissance des saules et
ensuite ces jeux là dans deux ou trois
ans vont atteindre une hauteur
approximative d'une vingtaine de pieds
on reprend les sélectionnés pour les
presser pour faire des panneaux
antibruit pour bloquer le bruit sur le
bord de nos autoroutes donc ça va des
produits végétalisée à faible empreinte
environnementale et qui sont beaucoup
plus attrayant cas des solutions à béton
par exemple si tout va bien wealth
management qui possède 268,7
d'enfouissement en amérique du nord
croit pouvoir ce qui est de cette façon
un
rend 25 à 30% de l'ensemble de ses eaux
usées à l'époque c'était l'agriculture
qui avait ici on utilisait le terrain
pour faire l'enfouissement des matières
rituel du mat noir on redonne avec une
culture cette personne-là en plantant
des sceaux ici non magron d'un radio
canada sainte-sophie